[Musica]
ci sediamo per un'intervista che ruoterà
attorno a un concetto a te molto caro
quello dell'applicazione
oltre il talento che vuole essere quindi
anche un messaggio che dallo sport si
può davvero declinare in tutti gli
ambiti innanzitutto ti abbiamo definito
ma lo parlano i fatti un vero e proprio
talento
scusate il gioco di parole nel trovare i
talenti ma la tua famiglia è stato così
tu nasci da una famiglia legata al mondo
dello sport oppure no
ma intanto buongiorno buonasera a tutti
per me un grande onore e un piacere se
devi con voi venite
insomma della provincia di modena modena
io ho trascorso tanti anni qui vicino
facendo le fortune di questo di questo
di questa provincia di una cittadina
importante come carpi e anche la mia
fortuna no non sono venuto da una
famiglia di sportivi diciamo ddt
frequentatori quello dello sport ma di
grandi sportivi perché mio nonno aveva
un bar quindi tutti andavano in questo
bar e quindi si parlava di calcio di
ciclismo io sono toscano quindi insomma
lo sport è sempre stato all'ordine del
giorno mai frequentato è mai capitato a
livello professionale professionale
professionistico insomma sempre parlato
tanto ecco quindi questo concetto
dell'applicazione oltre il talento
perché lo hai declinato anche nella tua
vita ti sei applicato molto per arrivare
fin qui sicuramente io credo che di
talenti ce ne siano tanti c'è un talento
nascosto in ognuno di noi
e in ognuno di voi
credo che però la differenza lo faccia
fra la grande applicazione la la ferocia
nel quotidiano nel credere fortemente
quello dove quello che uno vuole
arrivare allora con l'applicazione viene
fuori la differenziazione del talento
altrimenti talento rimane nascosto e
molti di noi e molti di voi non sanno
neanche di averlo 6 senza dubbio ho
riconosciuto manager sportivo se non
erro è anche ricevuto una laurea ad
honorem proprio per questo però ti
chiedo in pratica alcuni esempi di
quanto conti l'applicazione anche nel
mondo del calcio
ma uno che è un esempio mi piace
ricordare nel 1900 da calcio nei livelli
medi faccio massimo massimo la serie c è
da ragazzo facevo il settore giovanile
del prato e nel 1986 venne un calciatore
in prova negli allievi del prato questo
calciatore veniva dall'australia che il
papa aveva giocato a calcio
questo calciatore si chiama christian
vieri è arrivato non sapeva una parola
italiano aveva fatto un sacco di sport
ma nello specifico non aveva fatto
calcio nuvole a fare calcio però voleva
fare calcio in italia perché voleva
viveva per l'emulazione del papa questo
sogno ovviamente tecnicamente era molto
indietro e ancora non era sviluppato
fisicamente però quello che mi ricordo
io e proprio la grande volontà e la
grande determinazione per arrivare a
quell'obiettivo
ovviamente io mi ricordo ancora il primo
anno non fu non fu preso dal prato suo
mandato nei
derby provinciale addirittura due
categorie sotto la nostra
perché non era ritenuto valido e pronto
era un pochino indiano sono tecnicamente
lui non si è mai smontato i massimi
diceva sempre non ti preoccupare io
arrivo gli orari di arrivo e l'anno
successivo venne preso parte della
panchina poi piano piano
diventato un grande centravanti è stato
lungo periodo e portare centravanti del
mondo per un lungo periodo
e questa cosa qui detta così così
velocemente i cinque minuti su un parco
davanti a voi mi sembra veramente una
cosa diceva bene scontata un'acqua che
ci può stare magari era un po indietro
ma non così tanto in realtà lui era
veramente indietro lui è stato veramente
aveva un grande fisico che mette questo
per il vero suo talento e la grande e
una grande intelligenza ovviamente una
grande empatia una grande intelligenza
ma tramite la forza applicazione è
riuscito ad arrivare dove è arrivato e
quindi io questo ci sono sempre portato
dentro è stato un movente anche della
mia carriera che nel dopo calcio io
probabilmente nel calcio mi sono
impegnato tanto anche quando giocavo
ovviamente non riuscendo ad ottenere
grandi risultati però anche nel dopo
calcio diciamo che quell'esempio mi è
servito molto
e poi ovviamente
ci sono anche altri ma quello veramente
è stato una cosa incredibile da da non
essere preso né lievi de prato diventare
grande centravanti del mondo quindi
questo è un esempio che mi porto sempre
dentro parte l'amicizia che mi lega a
bobo data da sempre è già nelle parole
di don erio l'arcivescovo che ha detto
l'uomo non è un easy l'isola quindi il
senso del fare squadra applicato a tutti
i contesti
lo ha ribadito pochi giorni fa anche il
presidente mattarella legandole un'altra
emergenza quella del terremoto la
l'emilia romagna che ha saputo fare
squadra quindi ti chiedo quanto è
importante oggi
ma lo sport in generale ci dà un grande
esempio un grandissimo esempio lo dico
per i ragazzi perché riuscire nello
sport vuol dire avere rispetto delle
regole può dire del rispetto degli altri
vuol dire essere generoso altruista vuol
dire guardare al tuo compagno prima di
guardare dentro di te è questo questo ti
può portare a a trovare meno alibi di
quanto uno possa essere facendo
altrimenti perché sentendo parlare anche
gli altri speaker nella vita ognuno di
noi inconsciamente si trova degli alibi
lì non l'ho potuto fare perché c'è
quella cosa l'altro perché c'è l'altra
cosa si ma l'altro però ha fatto ha
fatto meglio perché è stato
avvantaggiato dal in realtà non è così
noi dobbiamo trovare il motivo per cui
non siamo arrivati a quello che volevamo
arrivare perché ci sono dei motivi
dentro di noi e li nel rispetto delle
regole degli altri dello stato degli
altri e li dell'altruismo e della
generosità si trova si trova il problema
per per occultare i nostri alibi per
chiudere
abbiamo sentito prima anche raccontando
la storia di delvecchio di marchionne
tommaso da barca parlato dello spirito
di sacrificio oggi spesso si accusano
anche le giovani generazioni di non
sacrificarsi più non è vero lo fanno
probabilmente in una maniera diversa
lo fanno anche
di trovare una propria strada magari per
passione con i ti chiedo la visione di
futuro un messaggio che vuoi lanciare
anche ai giovani qui presenti quale può
essere saggio è sempre di avere un
pensiero forte di fare nella vita
quello quello che è uno ovviamente ci ha
portato ma che piace perché poi alla
fine la capacità di apprendimento
studiando si vede che si ottiene quando
scelto pamina questa sostanza che nel
nostro cervelletto che quando abbiamo il
piacere di fare una cosa la impariamo
più velocemente più in fretta da cui
deriva anche doping no quindi io dico
sempre che la vita parlando prima con
uno speaker a tavola che ci sarà più
tardi è un andare contro le dipendenze
ci sono delle dipendenze positive noi
dobbiamo razionalmente prendere quelle e
delle dipendenze negative che possono
essere l'alcol e il fumo in mente queste
due che sono comunque delle dipendenze
la caffeina troppa caffeina non va bene
ma un pochino si è quindi trovare il
giusto equilibrio delle dipendenze
quindi del della dopamina
ecco questo criterio questa parola
ossessione è anche nel mondo del calcio
dello stato assolutamente che arriva che
arriva a grandi livelli e diventa
ossessivo del proprio quotidiano cioè
pensare fortemente la forza del pensiero
è la più grande forma d'energia che
esiste quindi un gran messaggio siamo
siate ossessionati in senso buono nel
senso positivo per costruire al meglio
il vostro futuro un grande grazie anche
stand aggiunto l'ho imparato è stato qui
con noi al 12mo gran 2022
[Musica]